let me let me put my cards on the table
i've always supported trans rights to
fairness and equality and i mean that
sincerely i want everyone
bro well you can say bro and that's fine
you're entitled to it's an uncensored
show and you've just proven it but let
me just say to you i always wasn't your
profile picture wasn't it
identified
no if you haven't understand all right
mr james let me jump in let me respond
to you let me respond to you please
don't just keep talking
let me finish you never so why do that
there are other ways to protest because
you're not listening to what i've just
said you're not emotionally connecting
to the fact that what i've just said to
you is one billion actually you're not
listening to what i'm saying no i am but
what i'm saying is we're in this what
you're not hearing is i'm agreeing with
your calls with the campaign
i just don't agree with the tactics i
want you to concede but i don't agree
with government criminality let me
finish i want you to concede that the
tactics you've been using are
self-defeating i think there's a better
more effective way to do it i think you
would if you're honest with yourself say
that actually this doesn't work this
kind of thing it might get you a few
lyrid headlines but i don't see any of
the british public go you know what i'm
watching this video i've got to join
that protest they think the opposite
yeah i think you're a bunch of people
wrecking people's lives do you
understand whatever you think let me ask
you a question do you understand and
appreciate what all these dog whistles
and talking points they're not dog
whistles
they are legitimate areas of concern you
can't just call everyone who disagrees
with you
please
if you keep swearing i'll have to kill
you you can go and have a look at their
websites you can have a look at their
twitters
like they are transphobic but i am
telling you was kicked out i just i just
said to you all right you're gonna have
women's place uk for being if you don't
want to have a civilized conversation
with me
okay look look i'm trying to give you a
chance i've explained my position
what is your problem with my position
i don't really know i'm going to leave
the interview now i kind of only came on
here because i thought it would be kind
of funny um but i want to say you're and
you're a fashion is the last time you're
a student i was a student when i was 19.
oh how old are you that was a long time
ago that was a long hard time
could i say that you're being aged
what i'm saying is how can you know
what's going on at university i'm just
reading this report you're reading a
report that says that students welcome a
freedom this is a higher education
policy that says that students want to
make sure that yes there is freedom of
speech but also that we're enabling
support for students um who can ask a
question
can ask a question without you getting
offended i'm not offended right you
don't offend me if you're trying
okay great
great go ahead
i don't like someone in this country i
don't want to offend you i want to give
you my honest opinion you give me yours
what is multiple truths
because last time i checked there's only
one truth
facts are facts that's it that's not a
very good philosophical outlook maybe
you should go
maybe you should go to uni it's cool but
anyway there's only one
question do you agree there's only one
truth to answer your question what does
it mean
it means that it's both possible to
enable freedom of speech as our students
unions do day in and day out um but that
it is also possible to make sure that
we're hearing the voices of people um
who you know are our campuses and our
communities of education are often the
homes of these students as well so when
they're saying i want to have the space
to speak out about what's happening here
i want to have the space to protest i
want to have the space to share
alternative views that is them
exercising their democratic right to
freedom of speech too what do you mean
they're not currently at school let them
go back to school just so you can all go
back to school that
that is why
we are uh talking
to work out our mechanism and we i hope
you talk about mr shaheen with respect
there's nothing
a girl should be entitled to go to
school in afghanistan the same way a boy
goes to you yourself said in august last
year that they had nothing to worry
about nothing to be scared about so if
you've got to worry about let them go
back to school give them the education
that they were having give them the
education that they deserve
just do it for for the remainder of this
interview identify as as atheists okay
wait let me finish as somebody that has
no religion right now i've just
identified as that this has nothing to
do with religion and again if you looked
at american laws which you clearly know
nothing about the supreme court is not
making a decision on religion this is
your religious bigotry towards people of
religion and bigotry doesn't believe in
god
the key point is it stops you from dying
i mean that's the whole point of the
vaccine piers
a young healthy man what was he in his
30s his chances of dying you're a young
healthy woman you've had this you've
been jabbed right i i have chosen to
disclose my jab status when i close the
disclaimer what are those people talking
about about transport that's my business
but whether one chooses to actually show
that at a border you can choose this is
the thing you should be able to make a
choice bodily autonomy is the most
fundamental human right novak chocolate
isn't asking for special treatment i
think it's incredible he's standing by
his principles he's a young healthy man
he can physical fitness yeah he doesn't
but he's also a role model who will have
definitely deterred a lot of people who
perhaps should have the role models
sports people standing up for their
principles they're a huge role model
well like the england footballers who
take a knee for a uh
but they'd happily go and uh compete in
the world cup in qatar where where we
have outrageous treatment of gay people
i have no problem with them taking
minnie i think it's good when they say
in fact funny enough when the players
take the near arsenal when i go the
entire crowd of sixty thousand people
white black and any type of they all
cheer
i don't hear a single dissenting voice
but it's hypocrisy because you can't you
can't i can't do that and then go and
play
now i've got an energy bill with 550
pound that i'm really struggling to pay
i'm sure cherylin
you famously walked off good morning
britain and you're in good company all
the best people do yeah you walked off
good morning britain when they asked you
if you insulate your own home and you
said you don't because you're a
hypocrite
have you started to insulate you i just
said to you i've got a 550 pound bill
that i can't pay right so just just to
be clear though you still don't insulate
your own home even though your whole
campaign you've got to start doing that
so we're talking about social housing i
understand the poorest in our society
we're saying that it won't happen unless
the poorest in our society can can do
the job and as we all know the poorest
in our society are struggling in poverty
but
i would take you more seriously if you
did insulate your own home so are you
only you're an electrician you know how
to insulate a home right but and for the
last 18 months i've been doing a job
that doesn't pay well peers right so i'm
not a very well-off guy and what you're
saying is that only people that can
afford 10 000 pounds to insulate and
retrofit a problem i'm not saying that
i'm just the ones that can have an
opinion on this and we're talking i'm
not saying that i'm just saying i'm
saying it would probably help your cause
if you stop lying down in front of mums
trying to take their kids to school or
people whose mothers are literally
having strokes and getting paralyzed if
you stop doing that and you actually
practice what you preach about things
like insulation people might be more
inclined to follow your campaign which
by the way just to finish on i agree
with we've talked about this just for
the record you have two daughters do
they go to school
yeah of course yeah yes of course
of course they do because you're in
dalaran they can go to school right yeah
they are observing hijab they are
observing any hijab and so well
that means we have not denied but
we have not done it to our people so
they do exactly
if your daughters do exactly what you
tell them they're allowed to get okay so
your daughter's getting education
because
wait a minute
your daughter's your daughter's getting
education because they do what you tell
them all right i'm glad we clarified
that
you